the way uh
podcast
how hard is it to succeed in a podcast
game is podcast game a hard game
would you say a podcast game is a hard
game if you love the podcast that you're
doing then it's not
okay if you if you corner yourself into
right if you corner yourself into
something that my friends always are
like i am tony i'm thinking about
starting a podcast i think i'm gonna do
you know cooking
with uh comedians or whatever you know
that's not even an example but i'm just
saying like if you corner yourself into
any type of pocket i think it becomes
miserable you know i i look i you know
i'm friends with joe and i see what he's
doing and not only is he
um you know killing it but he gets to
interview whoever he wants and talk
about whatever he wants for as long as
he wants to talk about that full control
and uh people are into it obviously his
listenership keeps going up every time
they try to cancel them he gets more
listeners more viewers it it's it's you
know well let me ask you a question and
he might have said open he didn't paint
himself into a corner any rogan episode
he could be talking to a fighter he'd be
talking to a comedian he could be
talking about
yeah give a [ __ ] yeah right but but
imagine if let's just say a person let's
make this person up
let's say there's a person out there who
is very well spoken
he's got 132 million followers on
twitter okay
let's say he even becomes a two-term
president
and then let's say he starts a podcast
with another guy whose name is bruce
okay who's a very famous singer okay and
they signed a 25 million dollar podcast
with spotify okay
a year later
spotify drops him
can you see that happening with somebody
that big
i mean that's pretty crazy for that to
happen but that's what just happened to
barack obama
why spotify dropped its deal
with barack and michelle obama tyler can
you go up so i can read this entire
article because this is almost
unbelievable make it a little bit bigger
so we can read this the obamas are
searching for a new home for their
podcast after spotify reportedly
declined to offer the former first
couple a new contract because they
didn't make enough personal appearances
on the stream and services brock and
michelle obama are reportedly in talks
with several companies including amazon
audible and i heart media on deal that
will likely be worth tens of millions of
dollars according to bloomberg news the
ex-president former first lady who
co-owned the production company higher
ground will reportedly decide on their
podcasting platform of their choice
sometime within the next few weeks
higher ground is said to be in seeking
an agreement that would allow it to
release uh shows on several platforms
simultaneously one of the sticking
points is in negotiation with spotify
and the swedish company instance uh in
uh insistence on an exclusive licensing
deal which they didn't want him to give
because they want to syndicate it
amongst everybody even if the obamas
produce podcasts for another company
those shows will in all likelihood make
their way to spotify anyways streaming
services want to want the obamas to make
more frequent appearances themselves in
order to generate more
buzz for the company but the former
first lady were probably willing to
commit to
no more than eight episode programs
higher ground was paid 25 million
dollars after signing with spotify in
2019
so only eight episodes is what they want
uh spotify is moving on power move is
this a smart move on spotify to drop
them a president who has got a
very strong audience his wife wrote a
book that sold 30 something million
copies you know whatever the number was
that she made 36 million dollars would
you say this was a good move on spotify
or a bad move on spotify
i think a good move tell me why yeah
because uh
spotify cares about actual listenership
and subscriptions based on what they're
paying for
and even though he has a lot of twitter
followers and she might sell a lot of
books
you have to bring them to the podcast
world you know what i mean so
you know rogan's signing with spotify
and having a built-in audience of a ton
of podcast listeners is different and
much much much more valuable than having
a politician who gave many public
speeches and has twitter followers like
typically like a lot of people a lot of
people have a lot of twitter followers a
lot of comedians and they and they suck
at selling out shows they can't fill a
venue
yeah and they tweet all the time and
they work on their following and they
post videos and all this stuff
but if you suck live you suck live and
they're not gonna get any better at
podcasting doing eight episodes every
year we know this right you naturally
get better at what you do they don't
want to do it they're literally clearly
there for the payday yeah for sure and
so um yeah what they should be doing is
just episodes for free and putting it
out everywhere anyway i mean if they
wanted to get good at that thing but
they're not going to get good well
that's not going to get winners if they
if they did if he did podcast him and
michelle did podcast twice a week
and they went one year straight do you
think they'd kill it yeah hundred
percent i do as well if they did it how
often twice a week twice a week yeah
at the beginning the article says they
did it how many times twelve times what
are you whatever than a year yeah i mean
they're they're what is it called you
just kind of like mailing it in or
packing it in you're just kind of you're
not you're not putting in the work obama
is right did you guys see they brought
him to the white house because
biden's numbers were taken so much it
looked like a rock star was in the white
house like
joe biden was behind him like trying to
chase him and every it's just dude
everybody will watch them every single
day pat let me ask you i mean you're a
businessman you're focused yep okay
we've done this is number one what are
we 140 what is this 142 not to mention
40 x amount that we 148 holy [ __ ] not to
mention the dozen or so we did back in
dallas under a different name
if you were only doing this
once a month
12 times a year yeah
how
what kind of bang for the [ __ ]
we feel it if you don't do it for a week
yeah yeah you feel it if you don't do it
for a week podcast game is a lot of work
it's it's but you have to do it steadily
but
i wonder with spotify spotify to give up
uh uh uh i actually think they made a
very smart move because obama's have to
have their show on spotify and spotify
doesn't have to pay them [ __ ]
they just have to be like what are you
talking i'm not going to pay you nothing
you're going to put it on here anyways
because you have to mess with my
audience okay
but the reason why we were willing to
pay rogan is because he agreed to be
what exclusive
if you're willing to do exclusive we'll
pay you 25 and you do one or two
episodes a week but if you want to be
able to put this everywhere why the hell
am i going to give you money i'm going
to give you [ __ ] yeah and i think that's
the right move they made good for
spotify spotify you said something
spotify is in the business of getting
listeners you talk such a logical way
you said that's capitalism yep yeah i
don't mind giving you money okay i'll
give you money but you got to bring me
listenership exactly you do great here's
what we'll pay you and tony said
something pretty funny before the
podcast he goes how many people do you
know that said hey did you catch that
latest obama podcast yeah yeah
i'm actually curious
to listen if you're if you're in the
comment section has anybody ever
listened to one of the podcasts and if
you've listened to all of them comment
below i'm actually curious the obama
hillary what's it called the obama with
hamstein i'm with him
no that's something
it's obama and bruce springsteen
i don't know should be much bigger than
it is regardless i think i think so
should it though i don't know i you know
obama and bruce springsteen you don't
think you type icons don't don't say it
because you don't like his politics it's
obama let me tell you i think obama has
the po i don't know that bruce
springsteen has the pool but i think i
don't know about people
i think people like michelle more than
they like a barack i think people are
over barack i think they're done with
him they're sick of him they're saying
that's 800 million dollars library he's
building in chicago they saw the 800
page
[ __ ] autobiography
this is the far end proud boy tyler
that's talking right now
get back
i think people saw exactly what barack
obama did to the country i think they
saw how he divided it and destroyed it i
think they saw that race relations were
at an all-time high before barack obama
took office i think they saw that he
said trayvon martin could be his kid i
think they see well through barack obama
i think you're absolutely wrong i think
that by the way that's the on the right
side of things those 80 plus million
people that would love to listen i don't
know why they aren't i don't think it's
absolutely wrong i think you're 20 right
i think there is 20 percent that he lost
but i do think there's a big like if i
if i'm spot let's just say valuetainment
and obama is agreeing to do a podcast
with us exclusive
and he's willing to sign a four-year 25
million dollar year contract with me and
he's gonna do two episodes a week in a
heartbeat i'll sign a 25 million dollar
contract with obama for four years for
two episodes a week but him and his wife
live
right here 25 million bucks what do you
want to do i'll give you 25 million
dollars up front and another 75 million
over the next three years you want to
come on let's do it he's going to get
the eyeballs period it's obama he's
young he's sexy he's attractive he's got
an audience not an audience that you
would kick it with but he does have an
audience that's the key barack if you're
listening pat just made a verbal offer
towards you do you think come on down to
florida do you guys think spotify would
pay how much do you think spotify would
pay joel biden to be on a podcast with
his wife how [ __ ] funny minimum wage
minimum wage he would just be trying to
shake people's hands i don't even know
it's like john dude that'd be so funny
that's not him though he at this point
of the game everybody knows that's
he got he became president for different
reasons it's a whole different situation
that's about to get very became
president for one reason it's just that
he wasn't trump that's no basically
that's it i i okay no you're you're not
yes but at the same time listen
strategically america made a stupid
mistake
because
during 9 11
everybody got behind america yeah and
the enemy was outside of america during
kovid
instead of making china the enemy which
would have brought the entire country
together
america may trump the enemy trump wasn't
the enemy they're idiots just so you
know that they're idiots what they did
whether you agree or disagree that was a
stupid move because
yes you got him to get out of office but
you also divided america so you may have
done something well we figured out a way
to get rid of that guy we've impeached
him 17 times who gives a [ __ ] people now
they're thinking other people are
enemies just because they have
differences together it's a very stupid
move made by america i don't i don't i
don't think that was the right movement
and you still can't say like we're not
holding china accountable because the
parent let's all be honest with each
other it definitely came from there it's
still people are still like that's kind
of racist if you're saying that it's
from them like no no it's not like
people are right now saying i would
listen to anybody okay so let's see the
erp i want to respond to you i listen to
anyone on ppd but obama right okay
uh
i would love to have obama on here to
ask him some real questions not because
oh my god we have obama obama no i want
to ask obama some real questions to see
what he contributed to
and what because remember when he said
something he said something a few years
ago says listen if you can't pull your
pants up and you're going and doing this
and you don't have the money to do so
you know you're broke like i don't know
if you remember this when he said this
like three four years ago
that's a statement to community you know
so so i think there's a part of him look
when you start making money
and you start really making some real
money your decisions change you start
realizing taxes
just for the hell of it i'm not for it
you know i remember when dave chappelle
got his first big payday
and uh obama was raising taxes on the
first term
chappelle's like dude this is the first
time i've made six million dollars can
you just wait one more year before you
raise the taxes right
but even chappelle was like dude i don't
want to pay that additional six hundred
thousand dollars so working hard making
money gets you to realize on certain
things with taxes but if you enjoy the
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]